this is the shanghai china wants the
world to see empty streets and orderly
covet testing lines millions of people
united with the goal of completely
eradicating kovit
videos like this paint a different
picture of residents being forcefully
removed from their homes to be taken to
overcrowded quarantine centers that look
nothing like the spacious highly
sanitized buildings presented to the
media
and when it was announced the buildings
in this area would be converted to
quarantine centers residents took to the
streets in a rare public protest that
was live streamed to the world
it is not unscathed in terms of moral
moral um you know vagueness but i think
it is doing the best it could given its
population density of a 26 million
person city the unspoken element this
epidemiologist says is that china knows
it has to tackle covet differently than
much of the world including countries
like canada because the inactivated
vaccines china chose to produce are far
less effective than mrna vaccines like
pfizer and moderna
that combined with low overall
vaccination rates could contribute to
the rapid spread of the highly
transmissible ba2 variant i think china
realizes that if it loses control
it will have
um
hell to pay a domestically if if it lets
the virus spread so they're making like
a calculated decision
and
obviously costing them economically but
you know in certain ways they have the
economic muscle
to tolerate and the political willpower
to tolerate it china is still trying to
achieve covet zero but it's also now
beginning to take a more targeted
approach while residents who test
positive for the virus are still being
sent to quarantine facilities officials
are slowly allowing some areas of
shanghai to open up while giving the
green light for priority businesses to
get the region's economic engine moving
again
mike trolite global news toronto